tonight's guest is the only female
comedian to ever win last comic standing
her latest album war paint is available
now please put your hands together for
my friend eliza schlesinger everybody
live
i know but people at home to see that i
actually love you
thank you for being here i understand
your album
it's a special it's not just an album
it's a special album i like this because
i don't know if your belly button is
above or below no one knows
remember that show kyle xy where the guy
like didn't have one shout out to that
shirt it's below
shout out to that joke interesting yes
i'm very i have a very long torso and
very small cat legs
back to the cat tell me about your dog
though cause i look i the point of the
monologue was it's fun to have opinions
not because i felt people already
blogging like dogs are treasures you
know what i mean
and they are i'm not a monster i played
with blanche backstage that's your dog
yes not your daughter
i love your dog daughter i love your
daughter doctor she's backstage i got
her all groomed and i put a bow on her
just on the off chance that someone was
like yes you can bring you have no
personality you can bring your dog on
with you
yeah it's hard if the dog were here i
feel like would just be talking here
pete but if she were here right i feel
like we'd just be talking about the dog
we would look at the dog look at the dog
i was just in new jersey and that's all
i heard look at the doggy anthony look
at the doggy
looks like we see it
that was very fran drescher it was she's
from flushing on the show it says
flushing i don't know where that is
which is we're going on her her show
personally kyle xy and the nanny name
frame whatever that show was the man
plugged in
that's what they said when i came out
they said don't forget to plug the nanny
my next guest is a very talented
comedian who loves the nanny
long canceled the nanny